Oh
you
No
okay welcome I'm Carol Becker I'm Dean
of the School of the Arts and I'm really
thrilled to be here welcome to all of
you to our graduating students parents
friends most dedicated faculty and staff
to a graduation speaker David picker and
to Erich Mendelsohn who's in the
audience who just honored a graduation
with the presidential Teaching Award and
of course to our honoree emily fisher
Lando and to her family and friends who
are here today I welcome all of you I
will begin by congratulating the class
of 2012
this class is comprised of graduating
students from 24 countries we have
marvelled at your brilliance at your
talents at you warmth at your compassion
at your camaraderie at your achievements
your devotion and your kindness to each
other we have immersed ourselves in your
work and we have bonded with you as our
students and as our colleagues and thus
we are very sad to see you go but we're
also very happy because we know that you
are already extremely well educated and
prepared to enter your various
professions we are certain that you are
going to succeed and we know that you're
going to make us very proud it has been
a joy to witness all your incredible
work this year you gave those of us on
the faculty and staff the gift of your
talents at Columbia and across the city
we saw a panoply 2012 the salon
sponsored by the interdisciplinary arts
council that so many of you shared
readings performances screenings and
exhibitions we thank the leadership of
the IAC for its tenacity and wisdom in
making that event happen we thank you
for your brilliantly directed and acted
theater thesis plays and actors theaters
thesis productions and all the showcases
I like that I like the theater has a
cheer your own share
Anna moms at a month of unforgettably
written new plays now downtown you're
going to make it very hard for film
which is next at Lincoln Center two
weeks ago we witnessed your amazing
achievements and those of past students
filling alice tully hall for the opening
of the 25th annual Film Festival to
enormous success it continued at the
walter reade theater at symphony space
at mcgraw-hill and then here at miller
for a night of student selects with an
astounding range of new short films and
screenplays presented throughout the
whole week we we have marveled at the
beautifully produced writers thesis
anthology with selections from every
brilliant second year MFA student and
the beautiful word for word addition the
translation project from literary
translation that is going across the
world and of course the monumental
visual arts thesis exhibition at the
fisher landau center of art in Long
Island City where more than a thousand
people packed the opening to see the
latest work of our spectacular artists
so these events were thrilling and not
only for us but to the thousands and
thousands of people who attended and
appreciated all that you've accomplished
so far as graduates you'll be joining an
incredibly illustrious group of alumni
who have gone on to extraordinary
achievements around the world this year
the overall success of our students and
graduates has been so overwhelming it's
much too extravagant for me to enumerate
here so I've chosen just a few examples
of alumni achievements to mention in
film three student alumni films swept
the eastern semi finals and have
advanced to the finals for the Student
Academy Awards taking bronze silver and
gold an annual an annual competition for
college and university filmmakers who
are Kim for the record exam which won
last year's annual alumni award for the
student film Christophe Kushnick for
hatch and Mark Roscoe for under the
winners the winners selected by
filmmakers from the Academy and now they
go to LA for a final during in theater
how lofty from 1984 graduate produced
the broadway revival of Evita that was
nominated for a Tony Award the gershwins
porgy and bess scored 10 tony
nominations including Best Director for
alumna Diane Paulus and 5 drama desk
nominations theater alumni beau willimon
was nominated for an Academy Award for
Best Adapted Screenplay for the George
Clooney film Ides of March based on his
play that he wrote here for farag at
north and Clarence qu 2010 12 12
he won the 2012 Yale Drama Series award
and Tony speciale one was nominated for
drama desk award for the play unnatural
acts in Visual Arts ski lodge rotman
from 2009 was selected to represent
Israel at the 2013 venice biennale and
we know that our faculty Sarah Z is
going to represent the United States at
the venice biennale it's going to be a
big year for columbia visual arts at the
venice biennale dana shoots his
retrospective if the face had wheels
began at the new bergen museum and
purchase it's traveling to the Miami Art
Museum the Denver Art Museum she has a
big show up right now at in Chelsea
writing the Pulitzer Prize and poetry
was awarded to Tracy k smith class of
nineteen ninety seven for her beautiful
anthology life on Mars Karen Russell our
alum writer swamp landia was one of the
three finalists none of whom was
selected for the Pulitzer in fiction so
I think we need to talk to that
committee but nonetheless it's a
fantastic tributes Kelly McMahons and
Beth raid Raymer both had books made
into films shown at Sundance the atomic
State of America and lay the favorite
and we had two Guggenheim's this year
from alumni 12 film alum Sharon Dhabi's
class of 2004 and another two visual
arts alumni Chitra Ganesh so those are
the achievements of our recent alums
our alumni as you see are everywhere
they're producing wonderful work around
the world and a short time you'll become
part of this great story of success that
really is the School of the Arts and
remember that we really want to hear
about this from you we want you to write
us and tell us and call us an email us
so we can tell everybody what you're
doing so I can brag about you at events
like this and so I and so that we want
to continue to be helpful to you in any
way that we can you will always always
always be part of the School of the Arts
and you'll always be part of columbia
university in the city of new york even
when you leave today i promise you that
i only wish that i had had the
opportunity to spend even more time with
you but I've had time to get to know
some of you and I'm very grateful for
that to hear you talk about your work
your time at the school the student body
in total represents 52 countries so the
24 countries are half of that of what
are all of you graduating to that today
and we cherish the breadth and the depth
of this mix very much we love very much
that the school is global it brings us
such amazing richness it's one of the
greatest strengths of the school its
sophistication and the reputation of
Columbia University globally is
reflected in all of you we have learned
so much from your presence about the
world about this new global world that
we're trying to adjust you and live in
and we now await the world's recognition
of all your talents before we begin our
program today I'd like to acknowledge
those people without whom many of you
could never have completed this most
essential part of your development as
artists and that is your parents and
your families and your friends so let's
have them stand
parents stand up stand up
and now I need to take a moment to thank
the Faculty of the School of the Arts I
would venture to say that there is no
more devoted faculty anywhere anywhere
and these are faculty with enormous
careers of their own with great
successes in the world winning awards
and a claim every day and still still
they are remarkably present and invested
in all of your success and I know that
you know that as students this is the
third year in a row when one of our
faculty have won the presidential
Teaching Award this year it was film
faculty Erich Mendelsohn and this is the
award this is the award everyone
teaching at Columbia wants and the
reason is it's the award that comes from
the students it comes from you in the
citation that was read by the president
about Eric I just excerpted one little
paragraph because we could go on and on
i think you know and this is to eric
your extravagant dedication to students
and generosity of time and talent are
legendary you have mentored numerous
filmmakers as they launch their careers
and their success in winning awards and
industry recognition speaks for itself I
would like Erich Mendelsohn to stand up
2012 presidential awarding
and now let's ask the faculty to stand
all of those who've supported you for
your time here
one more minute now we really get going
I want to thank all the staff this was
an extraordinary endeavor I think it
looks great the stage looks great and I
want to thank the Office of Student
Affairs I want to thank associate dean
of student Leila mayor and chicken and
Kenny and Dave and Allison are wonderful
directors of academic administration
from each program bill and Emma and
Julie and Sarah and those in
communications and events rich and
Christina who put all the images
together for the show and Daisy and all
those at Miller especially Brenna who
worked so closely with us as well as
those at neiman Center the dean's office
Mia Tony Nona Dean barb a bachelor I'd
also like to thank Chris Washburn and
Columbia's own undergraduate jazz
ensemble that are playing for you today
when I first came to the school I
thought why aren't we using our own
directors to choreograph graduation so
now we do and I'd like to thank very
much the director of the ceremony tyne
refaeli and our stage manager ashland
curry
they definitely got us into shape as
well as Susie Moses and Alison Ginsburg
I'd like to thank all the volunteers and
I'd like to thank Jenna ride who's not
here because her daughter is graduated
today from columbia college and she's a
very proud parent and she's with her
family so opening our program is our
guest speaker producer david b picker he
is the third generation motion picture
executive and producer his list of films
is so staggering it almost does not seem
possible it is an honor to have him with
us today and to introduce him we've
asked our chair of the film program the
incomparable IRA deutschmann
this is a very lucky task indeed over
the last dozen years or so within the
film program here at Columbia we've
embraced an idea that is so obvious that
it's remarkable it took us this long to
do it what we teach in the film program
is up the ultimate collaborative art and
yet the role of the producer the central
figure in navigating between the art of
storytelling and the necessary evil of
business was not stressed enough as a
producer myself I'm proud that creative
producing is now central to our program
also as a producer it makes me very
proud that our keynote speaker today is
one of us David picker was born into the
film business his father Eugene picker
was an executive at lowes theaters his
grandfather david v picker was one of
the founders of lowes which at the time
was the parent company of MGM for those
of you who don't know that david was
brought into the family business at a
young age and settled in at united
artists in the publicity Department
United Artists was not your typical film
company it had been founded by Charlie
Chaplin DW Griffith Douglas Fairbanks
and Mary Pickford in order for them to
have more control over their work both
creatively and financially even as the
company evolved and changed ownership it
remained a part in that it never really
had a studio it didn't produce its own
films and it remains stubbornly based in
New York the company financed and
distributed the work of independent
producers who were given creative
freedom well beyond any afforded by any
of the other Hollywood majors David
worked his way up within united with
United Artists organization finally
becoming president in 1969 his time at
UA was a watershed time for American
cinema and David was in the middle of
all of it he's the man who started the
James Bond franchise when he greenlit
dr. no From Russia With Love &
Goldfinger how's that
he greenlit the early Woody Allen movies
and would he kept making film his films
at UA for many years afterwards even as
he moved away from comedy and started to
take on serious filmmaking he greenlit
Richard less Lester's hard day a hard
day's night and help starring that
little band called The Beatles and how's
this for a short list of a few other
films that he brought to you a the
oscar-winning Tom Jones Midnight Cowboy
Last Tango in Paris among the many
European filmmakers he brought to united
artists were Federico Fellini Ingmar
Bergman Francois Truffaut Louie mal
Sergio Leone David went on to become an
independent producer bringing us such
films as Lenny starring Dustin Hoffman
directed by Bob Fosse which by the way
was nominated for six Academy Awards
smile directed by Michael Ritchie
juggernaut directed by richard lester
and then he was brought in by Paramount
Pictures as president of their motion
picture group and just like when he was
at UA he presided over an incredibly
fruitful period with such films as
Saturday Night Fever grease Terry
Malik's masterpiece days of heaven
Warren Beatty's heaven can wait and
Robert Redford's directorial debut
ordinary people he had a long
collaboration with Carl Reiner and Steve
Martin producing the jerk dead men don't
wear plaid the man with two brains he
later ran a company called lorimer films
Lorimar pictures and then he did a stint
as president and CEO of Columbia
Pictures so as you can well imagine the
list of films goes on and on and on his
most recent corporate position was at
hallmark entertainment where he got to
work in television he executive produced
a number of miniseries and
made-for-television films throughout his
long and storied career the one constant
was a belief that one did not have to
sacrifice quality in order to be
successful he represents what we at
columbia considers to be that consider
to be the true definition of a producer
the central figure who navigates the art
between the art of storytelling and the
necessary evil of business and he always
does so with such Grace and gentlemanly
behavior that he's a rarity in a
business that's full of bullies
there's a quote that I read somewhere
which I've been attributing to David in
my classes for years and I'm I guess
I'll find out today whether it's really
his or not he said when I look back at
my career I realized that if I said yes
to everything I said no to and I said no
to everything I said yes to I would have
broken even growing up I always knew the
day the name David picker from seeing it
on the screen and reading variety and
the other trades I'm now incredibly
happy that I can call him a friend
ladies and gentlemen David picker
that man sounds familiar he was talking
about but it is hard to believe the New
York Times this morning said at all
these functions the Lewis Carroll and
Robert Frost keep getting quoted and
it's become a banana tea well I'm not
going to agree with them I was lucky
enough to work with some extraordinary
creative people in my life and to study
under some and I was lucky enough to
study under electric course given by
Robert Frost and he used to read his
poems and I thought for the graduation
is this better I'm so sorry should I
start again my favorite quote from mr.
frost is one that I think should give
every single person in this room
something to believe in and it's from a
poem called a considerable spec and it's
about a poet who has a piece of paper
he's about to write and as he looks
across the paper he sees this tiny
little mite crossing and of course the
logical thing to do is to take the pen
and just dot the mic with a drop of ink
but he doesn't he watches the mic across
the page and the last two lines of the
poems are no one can know how glad I am
to find on any sheet the least display
of mind
in my career I have worked with many
storytellers I mean that's what we all
do whether we sing dance paint right
Phil direct act we are storytellers and
I have been fortunate enough to work
with some of the most extraordinary of
my time and so I thought rather than
lecturing you I would just tell you a
couple of stories some are very short
some were a little bit longer but i will
stay within my time frame a mob Bergman
made movies for us at UA we were the
only American company he permitted to
finance his films and I met with him and
we agreed to do four films together oh
no we had to do was approve the outline
which usually ran sometimes as long as
three pages I sorry three sentences and
he made three films for us in a row
persona passion of on an hour of the
wolf and then we haven't got to the good
part yet
and then the most expensive was at a war
film called in Swedish common and called
shame and I had on the receipt of the
previous three films always sent mr.
Bergman a telex telling him how pleased
we were how honored we were to be
distributing those films scammin arrived
I screened it in the United Artists
projection room and I really didn't like
it it was expensive it was actually over
budget it didn't seem to me soon perhaps
have the potential of a Bergman film
even at a lower cost and this was a much
higher costs and so I didn't send the
usual congratula Tory telegram and about
five days go by and Paul corner who was
mr. Bergman's agent is on the phone and
says and he I can't imitate his accent
but it was quite delicious he says David
mr. Bergman has not heard from you hey I
said I know and I sent mr. Bergman a
telex and I said dear mr. Bergman I
apologize for not getting in touch with
you but I didn't quite know what to do I
saw the film and I must say I didn't
respond to it but my response is not
important what's important is the
audience and I promise you we will do
everything we can to reach the widest
audience possible for your film yours
sincerely David and I got an answer from
mr. Bergman he said dear David the
important thing is you told me the truth
as far as the audience is concerned if
they do not like my film it will bother
me for about five minutes yours Ingmar
Bergman
Peter Brook thank Peter Brook is at
least in my personal opinion for what
it's worth the finest stage director of
my lifetime and I was privileged enough
to work with him when we agreed to film
his production of merits odd but he
invited me to Paris because he was
presenting a nine hour epic the
Mahabharata the great Indian tail and he
was curious as to what possibly we could
do in terms of film so I I went to Paris
and we were going to have lunch there
was a matinee that day and the matinee
started it at noon and ended at ten
o'clock that night and he wanted to stop
by on the way to lunch to talk to the
cast it was actually the one year
anniversary of the production so we
stopped by we go backstage they're the
cast is there and Peter says to me I'll
just be a few minutes David if you wait
here if you will and he proceeds to give
casts notes from the performance he had
watched two days before the show had
been running a year it was nine hours
long and Peter was giving his notes
Daniel day-lewis
Daniel day-lewis starred in a film I
produced called the crucible based on
Arthur Miller's play he played John
Proctor we wanted to shoot the film near
Salem and Ipswich and we found an island
that permitted us it was owned by a
trust to build the town of Salem on the
island Daniel heard about it and said he
had committed to the contract his
contract you know committed to the
run-in show but he called and asked if I
would mind if he came six weeks early
because he wanted to work with the
carpenters who were building the John
Proctor house and he did Daniel came and
worked with the carpenters and built the
home in which he lived Dustin Hoffman
I did a film with Dustin was the first
time I actually produced called Lenny I
had agreed to do the film there was a
producer involved who owned the show but
had made a deal with Bob Fosse to make
the film and in the Fosse deal false he
said I will do this film but you can
have a credit but you can't be involved
and he was smart this producer and he
agreed and Fosse I had made the deal and
then I had greenlit the movie and when
Bob heard that I was leaving united
artists to start a producing career he
asked me if I would join him and work on
the film together and I did it was a
long I could talk right now for five
hours and I believe you'd be interested
in almost everything I could tell you
about the making of that film but I'm
only going to tell you one thing about
Dustin Hoffman there's a scene near the
end of Lenny where this iconic comic is
really at the end of the road he's a
total drug addict nobody's going to see
him anymore and he has a scene where he
has to come on stage to a nightclub
where there's three people or five
people attending and he is so out of it
that he he wears shoes socks underwear a
t-shirt and a raincoat and he's stoned
when he gets to the theater and he's got
to go out and perform in front of ten
people who couldn't care less that he's
even on the stage it was a long shoot
and it was a six-day-a-week shoot and we
had one saturday that we were not going
to work and dustin came to me and asked
if he could arrange the schedule so that
the saturday that we were not shooting
could be the Saturday before the Monday
that he would like to shoot this
particular scene of course we could
accommodate that so we finished shooting
friday and the company was off Saturday
and then company was off on sunday and
monday was the scene that Dustin had to
perform he was a 730 call we all got
there Dustin pulled up and he had on
each arm an attendant who kind of looked
like they were holding him up
I was a little scary and he came in and
he asked if he could talk to Bobby and I
and he did and he said listen I think I
can do a couple of takes he said I
didn't quite know how to handle this
because I didn't want to take drugs but
I know I have to appear stoned so I
decided to hire these two gentlemen on
friday and i haven't gone to sleep since
they arrived they have kept me awake and
I'm prepared now to do the scene and
when you see that movie again you watch
that scene and you see an actor
performing that is the ultimate in
commitment in care and in art that's
what these people do
I don't have a lot of advice for you i
really don't you want it you go for it
how I don't know don't find somebody
that you believe in or believes in you
and do it with them get any job on any
level on any project that interests you
even if you have to do it for nothing
because I'll tell you something about
people in the arts and I speak more
specifically about movies in this case
but I know this to be true they respond
to people caring more than anything else
if they see somebody who wants
responsibility and by that I mean get me
a cup of coffee clean the trailer drive
me here they respond to people want to
be involved who want to learn more than
anything and I can give you and I'm not
going to bother you now but I could give
you ten examples from Jeffrey Katzenberg
to Academy Award producing Lawrence mark
who were pas on my movies and who have
found a way because of their absolute
total determination to succeed I want to
congratulate a group of people you
parents you parents have put up with a
lot
could I absolutely believe based on what
I've seen not only today but other times
that I've been in college campuses but I
have to say I go to Columbia more than
any other place I absolutely believe
that what you have given your kids is
something so valuable and you should be
so proud of that you are entitled to an
enormous enormous level of support and
love I'm going to close and I'm going to
close with what I wish for you and it's
something that I read but was also said
to me before I even read it by somebody
that was privileged to know named Truman
Capote Truman Capote said when asked
what did he hope to attain in life he
said I want to get to the top of the
mountain because although the air is
thin the view is exhilarating what I
want for you is that air for you to
breathe and that view for you to see
congratulations
David that was totally wonderful just
wonderful thank you we have so many
wonderful things today and now we have a
very special event today we are
recognizing the great art collector and
philanthropist emily fisher landau and
it is my honor to introduce her to you
and then to present to her her citation
so this is my introduction some of you
know her very well and some of you don't
know her at all over the last five years
one of the gifts of my position as dean
of faculty has been getting to know
emily fisher landau renowned art
collector philanthropist woman of the
world and great grade friend of the
school of the arts a book her family
created about her life is called we had
such a good time and so she has had but
it has not always been an easy time life
has presented her with the most
difficult challenges yet she has
triumphed a result of an enormous
resilient spirit emily fisher landau
loves the energy and the daring of young
artists accepts their originality
eccentricities passions and the process
of their work each year for the past
five years she has hosted the MFA visual
art thesis exhibition in her fabulous
official Landau Center for the Arts in
Long Island City this glorious 25,000
square-foot space open to the public in
1991 houses her enormous contemporary
art collection designed by the acclaimed
architect of exhibition spaces max
Gordon the center is a dream each of the
last five graduating classes in Visual
Arts has had access to this museum
quality venue for its final exhibition
as a result the work has looked
absolutely the best resulting in
wonderful opportunities for many of our
students Emily's 1100 piece art
collection spans 1962 the present
and includes such artists as jasper
johns Donald Judd Agnes Martin Robert
Rauschenberg site wombley Matthew Barney
head whoosh a Rothko and of course Andy
Warhol several of our Faculty's work
including that of John Kessler kiki
smith and carroll Walker also has become
part of the collection and she recently
gifted 367 pieces to the Whitney Museum
of Art at the time Whitney director Adam
Weinberg said that all the artists Emily
had collected were of interest to the
Whitney this is a tribute would be a
tribute to any collector the gift is a
remarkable one worth millions and
millions of dollars but also invaluable
in its representation of the history of
American contemporary art each year the
center continues to acquire work from
young artists our students often benefit
from emily's famously astute I as she
walks through the show with her daughter
candia Fisher herself a great art lover
and friend of our students and they
select several pieces that they think
should be part of this monumental
collection we are thrilled to have had
and continue to have access to such a
great collection and to the visionary
space that she chose to purchase in what
was then a remote setting for art Queens
but which is now an art destination home
to such other prestigious institutions
as ps1 the Museum of the moving image
the noguchi museum socrates sculpture
park and so forth what does it take to
build such an extraordinary collection
and to be such a deliberate patron of
the Arts first I think it takes passion
you have to love art and you have to
understand it not intellectually
necessarily but in an intuitive and
heartfelt way Emily would have loved to
study art making but this was not meant
to be still she has a great feel for it
art is essential to her life and it
provides a constant source of pleasure
and learning to be a collector you have
to have love you have to love artists or
at least the way they work and
collaborating with her dear friend and
curator of the center bill cats she
often bought work before others
recognized it's value simply because it
spoke to her in a profound way her
passion and understanding of the work as
well as her daring comes from a very
deep place in her and a desire to always
maintain a sense of possibility for the
future what the world could be should be
if it were truly responsive to human
emotion and also to play emily is a
visual person and like many artists
she's dyslexic but when she was in
school teachers didn't understand this
problem and having suffered these
difficulties and these indignities she
also became compassionate to others that
were challenged in similar ways as a
result she and her family have invested
in a professorship at Harvard University
where they studied dyslexia and they
teach the latest findings she's
encouraged elementary school schools to
diagnose students with this difficulty
early on to help them succeed her
concern and generosity has led to
increased awareness of this challenge
the Fisher family many of whom are here
today has been a great benefactor to the
School of the Arts in many ways
including the gift of the Andrew Fisher
fellowship fund named after Emily's
grandson fellowships that have benefited
so many students over the years and
helped them to complete their education
of Columbia the Fisher family's
generosity is legendary they founded the
Fisher houses program to provide
low-cost residences for the families of
patients receiving medical care at major
military and VA medical centers are
you're looking at the images
what happened we have some foot we have
to get bet them back so we have a great
last one so here we go that they founded
the fisher houses program to provide
low-cost residences for the families of
patients receiving medical care at major
military and VA medical centers around
the country to give families a place to
stay so that they might be close to
their loved ones during these times and
the Fisher family has also been involved
in the founding of the intrepid
sea-air-space museum emily fisher Landau
has a great eye for art she has a great
eye for people she has a tremendous love
and joyfulness for life she has been a
great friend to the world of artists and
art making and to those whose gifts
might not fit easily into established
systems as well as a great friend to
those who have served their country and
whose families are not always well
provided for in recognition of all of
these forms of generosity and brilliance
and with deep respect for all her
achievements in the arts we are
delighted to present to emily fisher
lando today an honorary professorship of
the Arts at Columbia University School
of the Arts and I would like now to read
the citation so Emily can you join me at
the podium
and so it says Columbia University
School of the Arts in the city of New
York honors emily fisher lando visionary
champion of art and artists as honorary
professor of the arts in grateful
recognition of which the Dean of Faculty
of the School of the Arts has a fixed
her signature to this certificate in New
York on the 16th day of May in the year
2012 this is for Emily
I think the only thing i might say that
would be somewhat unusual is the fact
that i was born learning disabled
dyslexic but nature gave me this
wonderful gift of the eye I could walk
into a gallery with art all around the
room by one artists and I could tell you
which is the best and that's a gift
so I thank you very much for this
wonderful honor this is a day I will
ever ever never never forget thank you
and from the bottom of my heart I can't
tell you how much this has meant to be
okay now we have having given Emily her
recognition now we recognize all of the
graduates the chairs of each program
with the assistance of the directors of
academic administration will present the
degrees and we begin with visual arts
chair Gregory Amman off then we move to
a theater and Arnold Aaronson and then
to writing and standing in today because
Vinny is in Jordan we have the chair of
the poetry concentration the marvelous
poet Lucy Brock Boyd oh and we're
finished with IRA deutschmann in film so
we'll begin with Gregory Yemen oh I can
help Thank You Carolyn let me add our
words to thanking Emily for and candia
and the Fisher family for all the the
years of great generosity those of you
who have seen our exhibitions at the
Fisher Landau center and I encourage you
to go today rush over to Long Island
City wait till I'm finished and then
feel free to go over you can skip these
other people I kid oh come on grow up
but we want to thank Emily the
exhibition is extraordinary as it has
been for every year for the fifth year
it's extraordinarily beautiful and it's
a testament such an honor for us to have
that wonderful Museum thank you so much
Emily in candia thank you thank you
and then of course i want to thank our
27 graduating artists they have
sacrificed much they're an extraordinary
group they have formed a community that
I think well that I know will extend
well beyond their years here with both
the class below them the class above
them and all the alumni that are so
active in the art world so on behalf of
the faculty I'll just say we're not
worthy to you and thank you come on
there's no track you know why she's
orange and that's your favorite color
now why is this artist orange because
orange is the color of the Sun it's the
best more energy than any other color am
i right it's the color of light so this
is an artist that is working in their
studio all along no its begnettes make
art they're making it because they
believe in something they want to make
something happen there's never happened
before that's our artists sometimes they
fail sometimes they succeed this heart
has just exciting so they call their
friend they call it friend another
artist comes over would you take a look
at what I'm doing the artist
this is great work in other maybe
they're a little older and I have some
kind of judgment they want to help the
starter so they look at the work in the
studio I say this is fantastic great
work let me help you I know somebody who
do they know let's take a look I have to
remember who they know they know and our
other this isn't our love erratically I
should be learning from sorry it's me
this is a collective an art lover maybe
they buy things maybe they just collect
things but they are very interested in
what the artist has and then you have
this collector then calls the dealer or
somebody who has a space to exhibit the
work we have an art lover and we have
somebody who's a gallery or space it
doesn't have to be a commercial venture
now then they pick a little bit together
and they think well let's call somebody
I know someone who writes about our
they're called a critic or does my god
awesome crickets so the cricket comes in
looks at the art cost to the dealer cost
the collector thinks this is great work
I want to write about the cricket halls
he curator a curator comes in looks at
the work is very interested in the world
maybe they
nonprofit space do they represent a
museum but their curator working pretty
well so far you never know all right now
the critic writes books and writes
magazine articles you know all kinds of
things get published so this is an art
publisher who has to publish some of the
things that critic rice so we'll think
of publishing I think of art books here
they are with this work ever remembered
here now where are we going to put the
art where's the curator work the curator
works in the museum of course I museum a
nonprofit space somewhere to put the art
up so that everybody can see it so
here's the museum who do we have in the
museum while we have people that fix up
the art because artist I'm very careful
those are called restores we've got
education people we have a whole flock
of people that are working to take care
of that are there's museum now we're the
fun part we have the artist Orient now
here in Colombia we have one of the
great art history departments anywhere
in the world the artist stories are
putting the art contest at making
historical precedent they're also
writing books so all right and then now
we have a very special
libraries we have to get that in here
somewhere then Avery library where ever
you do this now we have another special
class of people these are the people who
do art theory be with me here this is
the nation-state of France getting about
us here's columbia columbia blue
columbia blue this is all godliness
astatine this is still be the same
university these are all of us many of
them are artists of one the artist is at
the bottom but everyone is on the
artists shoulders none of these things
exist without that person in that studio
so hardest rides the bus your large
everyone else follows hold everybody up
and make your work
visual arts graduates make their way to
the stage I'd like also to introduce our
director of academic administration who
works tirelessly to make the place run
along with her staff the fabulous Emma
balzs let's hear it back here for Emma
let's get started Cara crib Irene unshy
Julia bry Benjamin Sebastian persol
black
Robin Sarah Cameron
Nathan catlin
leah marie cetera Caitlyn see cherry
lisa michelle cop jeremy michael kuya
and exec you wish
Ben ho
Christina and Lee Alexandra lemon Molly
Elizabeth floor urania spazzy amiga
Susan Nadine Moloch
Claudia Nolasco Beatrice and possums
Jordan Spence wrathe's Corey Thomas
Radel
Alexander Whitaker Smith
maria theresa stuffier
Matthew cada Watson James L John
yakiniku
oh it's nice for what afternoon I get to
feel like Stephen Colbert following
Gregory is like being on the worst bill
on a vaudeville act so congratulations
to the stage managers managers and
producers drama turds directors and
actors I think I skipped playwrights of
the class of 2012 and welcome to the
world's second oldest profession so for
three years you have endured basements
with malfunctioning heat and ventilation
drafty towers stifling classrooms the
occasional rat on a daily basis you have
run marathon journeys from 132nd street
to dodge hall to Shubert alley to
Chelsea and beyond and yet somehow
despite overworked lack of sleep and
even a lack of a theater you created
fascinating powerful often revelatory
art I normally don't like the phrase the
magic of the theater it is trite its
sentimental but how else to describe
that's not a laugh line ah how else to
describe what you have accomplished we
would all agree that there is nothing
magical about Shapiro or nashor Horace
Mann or riverside and yet week after
week we enter one of those spaces and a
transformation occurs for a few moments
the outside world melts away and with
the simplest means you have transported
us to ancient Greece Renaissance England
France Spain the worlds of Chekhov Brett
Beckett or some new cosmos that you have
created
for us how does that happen I've been
making and creating and teaching theater
for over 40 years I started minus 20 and
I I still don't fully understand but
somehow with the help of your teachers
you have learned or absorb these
mysteries and now you join an ongoing
river of artists with sources in
Aeschylus arata muni z ami GAO ming and
generations of griot's with names that
have long been lost to history you are
about to commence on a lifelong journey
in which you will be the new creators of
american theater or the theater in the
ten countries which you represent so i
have a request actually it's more like a
desperate plea I want you to make
interesting theater your initial
response is probably the what else would
I be doing well I don't know about you
but I find a lot of theater out there
created by well-intentioned intelligent
talented people to be anything but
interesting ah Peter Brook who are
speakers as folk of concludes his book
the shifting point with a parable in
which God tells people that the secret
to theater is interest but Brooke
wonders why the uninteresting is so
appealing and he says this is quote what
makes so many people in the theater
applaud so often and so vigorously what
is actually of no interest to them
whatsoever if the word interesting seems
bunnell is because it has lost its
meaning it is a word that we use when
we're at a loss for words it is a
euphemism for bad gee I read your play
and it was really interesting
but if we go but none of your plays of
course but uh if we go back to the roots
of the word its definition is to make a
difference to be of importance to effect
with a feeling of concern to stimulate
too sympathetic feeling to excite the
curiosity or attention of several
cultures have mythological or origin
stories for the theater that often hinge
on the notion of interest for instance
in Japan the Sun Goddess angry about
something hid in a cave plunging the
world into darkness in order to draw her
back out again the other gods created a
performance that evoked laughter when
the goddess poked her head out of the
cave to see what all the laughter was
about the dancer caught her attention
she was interested and daylight returned
to the world john cage once to find
theatre is anything that engages the
eyes and the ears perhaps an overly
broad definition but not if we truly pay
attention to the word engages I think
that part of the issue is size too much
of our theater is small I believe like
Aristotle that size matters
but Aras toddles Goldilocks formula a
work of art should be neither too big
nor too small seems to have led to a
theater that is well uninteresting as
you know Tolstoy declared all happy
families are alike each unhappy family
is unhappy in its own way well not in
the American theater in our theater all
the unhappy families are alike as well
we are barage with unhappy love affairs
dish dysfunctional families the
unfairness of life theater should give
us something we cannot experience in the
real world if I want to wallow in broken
hearts and dysfunctionality and rotten
luck I'll go home and look at my
scrapbook
just just kidding I don't have a
scrapbook but you may say isn't this the
basis of most drama sure the vast
majority of our classics are about
unhappy families but not the ones you
grew up in you want dysfunction look at
Oedipus the Oresteia Electra Hamlet look
at King Lear which revolves around an
irascible old man probably in the early
stages of Alzheimer's and is ungrateful
daughters and their loutish husbands but
that's not what the play is about much
of Death of a Salesman is set in the
loehmann's kitchen but no one ever
accused it of being a kitchen sink drama
did Sophocles have a difficult
relationship with his father did
Shakespeare of trouble with his children
did molire have problems in love let's
check off allergic to Cherry's we don't
know and it doesn't matter actually
molire did have problems in love but
that's a different story in the real
world as your teacher advisor I hope
friend I am concerned about your
tribulations and your triumphs but as a
spectator at the theater I don't care
about your personal problems or your
gripes or your quotidian encounters with
a mundane I want to be surprised I want
to be taken where I've never gone before
I want to see the world in a new light I
want to use Aristotle's word magnitude
I'm not asking for physical size you can
have as Shakespeare said great
reckonings in little rooms or as the
saying goes all you need for theaters
two boards into passion but I want you
to think large thoughts I know you can
do it because I've seen it in your work
here so your mission should you choose
to accept it is to go forward and make
theater interesting again
congratulations
I'd like to invite the graduating
theatre arts students to line up at the
stage and i would like to introduce
Julie Rossi our director of
administration on academic
administration who will announce your
names and while you were lining up I
would like to thank Jamie Hardy for all
of her work that keeps the theater
program line
all right Johan Oh Larry no SI quiere
Jessica Kaplow Applebaum Rafael
alejandro Benoit Linda Lorena bora
gallus david joseph carter Donovan
Christie jr. Michelle coat Sara
Elizabeth Iseman Danielle sherry vital
ssin Lila Feinberg Shannon Sarah billion
Kate Flanagan Simone edenia ha nu chi
matthew michael hurley eddie ray jackson
J Luke jasky Ellen anger ja Fred Julia
may Jonas Mehmet Oh newer Carol Liu
David Douglas Glasgow
Daniel Levitt way e lynn adam daniel
Lubitz Jimmy maze Philip Andrew lays
mancilla Natalia Miranda Guzman Daniel
William matera tondo Evan richard
o'brien Melissa Schultz O'Donnell Jensen
Austria Alya young h park Melissa and
Pedro
Caroline Jane Prue
brittany nicole wray Mert Tatiana Gloria
Rivera Stephen Craig row luis enrique
Santiago cocoa maria schneider Marissa
Danielle Schwartz Simone Marie Scully
marine and Francois zle David rose are
Stearns Amy faith Steinman
Ashley Kelly teta Tiffany Rosalinda Vega
danielle lee van Gaal Ching Jean
is there some pretty tough act to follow
ah and I know that our chair beanie
kirschenbaum who's now taking a little
dip in the Dead Sea for real she's in
Amman Jordan setting up a satellite MFA
program there tonight she will camp with
the Bedouins and then she'll be back and
I'm taking her place but I know last
year she read to our graduates a list of
jobs that you will be capable of doing
after you graduate from here I also
wanted to say that Gregory has his
orange dolls and Arnold well they're
other colors too has the biggest mulu in
the audience and I think the writers
should get no more
and had I known there was going to be
such frolicking I would have brought my
poet finger puppets when I was in
graduate school here we used to do the
death of poets by finger puppets no one
does it anymore but we'll be glad to
teach you also I finally I was going to
read you a poem that was published in
1667 by the poet John Milton it's epic
it's in blank verse it's in 12 books
it's 10,000 541 lines long and I thought
we could sleep over
we can instead I'm gonna read a brief
slick slick palm by the poet Richard
Wilbur and this is a poem written to his
daughter as he listens as she is trying
to become a writer herself and I think
the close of the poem represents how all
your teachers feel about the what's yet
to come in your lives it's called the
writer in her room at the prow of the
house where light breaks and the windows
are tossed with Linden my daughter is
writing a story I pause in a stairwell
hearing from her shut door a commotion
of typewriter keys like a chain hauled
over a gunnell young as she is the stuff
of her life is a great cargo and some of
it heavy I wish her a lucky passage but
and now it is she who pauses as if to
reject my easy thought and its figure a
stillness great ins in which the whole
house seems to be thinking and then
she's at it again with a bunch clamor of
strokes and again is silent I remember
the dazed Starling which was trapped in
that very room two years ago how we
stole in lifted a sash and retreated not
to affrighted and how for helpless our
through the crack of the door we watched
the sleek wild dark and iridescent
creature
batter against the brilliance drop like
a glove to the hard floor or the desktop
and wait then humped and bloody for the
Wits to try it again and how our spirits
rose when suddenly sure it lifted off
from a chair back beating a smooth
course for the right window and clearing
the sill of the world it is always a
matter my darling of life or death as I
had forgotten I wish what I wished you
before but harder congratulations
I'd like the writers to line and i'll
introduce our much-loved program
academic administrator bill wadsworth
well the writers are assembling i just
want to also thank clarence koo who does
things during the day besides writing
plays the writing program and ed
currents rechsteiner for all their hard
work this past year
you
Marnie Lee burger Patricia Elizabeth
Barry marina Blitzstein Sheeran
borthwick Priya shandra sigaram Alicia
shine Chang Catalina gym ciao Leia Brody
damn ski Sasha Fletcher
Chris Derek Williams Emily Rose hurt
Celyn Joshua's Scott how's Sasha Aaron
lang Michael yi Xiao Li Hillary Lecter
advil Evan
kelsey and moats Connors Mike Murphy
Steve Nelson
Matthew Joseph Parker Jonathan Philip
Rappaport Gordon Chenoweth's our the
third Anna albertson Spiegel Brian Lewis
Potomac Jesse Athena deny thiessen
Alexis Linda tonti Rachel Molly Trager
Astri an arbonne Islander Juliana
schwenn one David shinwoo
thank you
and last but not least
all right I don't have any props I'm not
particularly theatrical and lord knows I
am NOT poetic in fact if I was going to
try to express myself in the way that we
express ourselves in the film program
here it would be up there on the screen
but unfortunately i'm still trying to
get it financed so instead i'm going to
just pitch it all right so on behalf of
the film faculty I'd like to
congratulate the class of 2012 over
there
over the last however many years we've
put you through many versions of hell
there was the three to five minute
version the 8 to 12 minute version and
the all-important thesis version there
were all those pages to write the
marathon classes the Wednesday's that
lasted from ten in the morning until
nine at night the conflicting notes on
your latest draft or your latest cuts
the deadlines that came and went and the
pressure to perform while surrounded by
peers who always seemed to make it look
easy and I forgot to write down also
there was the air conditioning
challenged rooms and the occasional rat
is our load attention well you've made
it to the other side you are a producer
a director a screenwriter a scholar a
critic a curator or some combination
thereof so as you step out of the cocoon
of this academic environment and into
the great unknown what's next certainly
a question a lot of people up there are
asking
I'm reminded of the fact that as an
independent filmmaker you almost never
have a moment to celebrate it always
seems that every time you've scaled some
kind of mountain you can barely take a
breath before there's another mountain
to climb the day the financing comes
through so you can finally make your
film who has time to celebrate now you
have to go right into production who has
time to celebrate when you complete the
film when you need to focus on doing
whatever's necessary to get to its
intended audience it's always like that
isn't it one mountain after the other
but you've chosen a calling that never
gets easy get used to it embrace it you
came to this school not because you
thought it was a quick road to riches
but rather because something burned
inside you Walt Disney fit of all people
famous famously said we don't make
movies to make money we make money to
make more movies
I vividly remember the moment in my life
when I began to recognize the power of
this medium I was blown away by the
moving images on the big screen and the
inexplicable emotion brought about by
the communal experience in the dark I
was drunk with the possibilities of
using that power for social or political
change I wanted to share that magic with
anyone and everyone who would listen in
marburg man once said no art passes our
conscience in the way that a film does
it goes directly to our feelings deep
down into the dark rooms of our souls it
was no other choice for me and I'm sure
that was true for many of you so what
next indeed i have a few small pieces of
advice and i have to say that these
probably would be good pieces of advice
for everybody here not just the film
students number one don't be Precious
about your next move look kindly on any
opportunity even if it seems like it
might be a detour on the road you've set
out for yourself at every juncture your
meeting potential collaborators finance
ears employers you never know where your
future is going to come from number two
look around at your classmates they are
the key to your future success the old
saw about how it's who you know in
Hollywood it's actually partially true
just keep your eyes different sorry
you're still here starting out with a
strong community that will be rising
through the ranks together number three
don't be envious of others don't compare
your rate of success ever to your
classmates everyone Rises at different
speeds and luck definitely can be a
factor just keep your eye on your own
work and root for each other because
that goodwill will indeed pay off and
number four don't get discouraged as
demanding as this program is the life
awaiting you with rare exceptions will
be just as challenging I know that all
of you have heard the doom and gloom
about how
the traditional ways of earning a living
through filmmaking or film scholarship
are disappearing yeah there's a lot of
chaos out there right now but out of
chaos comes opportunity as a society
there's never been more demand for
people with the skills that you have
honed as the old methods of production
distribution and dissemination of
information inevitably involve evolve
into something new something that is
already beginning to take shape we're
seeing the beginnings of a gold rush to
get control of the storytellers the
people who have the talent to create
powerful stories within these new
paradigms so while there may be a lot of
rocky times ahead don't give up your
dreams there's a lot of opportunity
ahead but with opportunity comes
responsibility the art of storytelling
goes back to the dawn of man from cave
paintings which by the way were the
first story boards to to imax mobile
phones and the internet the means of
storytelling is constantly evolving yet
storytelling in all of its forms remains
the glue that holds a society together
it's fundamental to politics to religion
to advertising to business and to art
over the last century it's become clear
that visual storytelling specifically
has become one of the most powerful
means of moving people moving them to
laugh moving them to cry moving them to
act on their better instincts and in the
wrong hands moving them to their worst
so what you do is important you have a
responsibility to use your talents in
ways that will hopefully make us a
better world congratulations to all of
you for what you've already accomplished
and i think i can speak on behalf of
everyone at the school when i say we
can't wait to see the work ahead
congratulations
I'd like to invite the graduating film
students to come on around and and I'd
like to introduce our incomparable
director of academic administration
Sarah Mason who will reveal to us for
the first time which ones of our
graduates have middle names
and I just want to say leading our
graduates is Hana cipher who's my right
hand and I couldn't do it without her
Darren Richard Anderson Valerie Margaret
pshaw Jessica Caldwell christina s cho
Joseph Garth claim Greg legaspi conde
Jedediah Harlan Cowley Bobby kashif
Joel Robert Davenport Gabriella
then tomorrow
Chanel Samantha Elaine Nathan Patrick
floody William burr Gerard David Gregory
got Nick Randall Eric green andrew james
daniel Hauser house' pure lace daughter
Jonathan Aaron Kaufman Gerald Joon Kim
first off Robert cushnie Anna nozzle
Raven
and he said naraz frutos alexander lee
lublin ER Natasha John's messenger Sarah
Michelle nervosa Olivia Claire Newman
Brittany Alexandra Parker Brian Matthew
Parker Robert leave on pool Jessica
Marais des rambo mark jason Brazeau
jasmine media ribeiro belkis Ezra side
um
Levi kayse Shrum look Ashley seaboard
Benjamin John second jomar so such a
bald then carries finds born son Jasmine
bahaar Tekken her Rory and Thomas Jada
Denise Thompson should cream Hasan
Tillman Matthew Jude Torgy michael
anthony toscano matthew Tyler
Callie Elizabeth watch maria cristina
alamin neta alexandre de pollo Vincent
Barwin Katherine grey Jane Valentine
soon Stephen David Mears Jonathan
Robbins tarini sridhar on Petra Dawson
congratulations to all of you now let's
have a party everybody to dodge
everyone's invited to the reception
let's have some fun
Oh
you
when was that